yeah it's a great honor dennis you were
introducing me yesterday and now
i can introduce you dennis's lead data
scientist at big data republic and the
earth
experience at various companies
even before that he studied econometrics
and political
science so short question dennis
what made you choose political science
that's a that's an interesting question
so
uh actually uh when i was studying i
thought
i wanted to become a politician um
but then i realized actually that most
people would hate you
when you're doing your job so then uh
yeah i actually got into data science to
uh yeah to be sort of more
actually practical in what you build and
have an impact there okay cool and
everybody loves you well that i i hope
but one can only wish yes
well the floor is all yours so my name
is
dennis ramond and i'm a lead data
scientist at big data republic
and today i will talk you through
how together with our client
liberty global um we are monitoring
a large-scale tv streaming service using
artificial intelligence and specifically
i'm going to talk about how we use graph
analytics to
achieve this
let me just get this clicker working
yes so you may not have heard of liberty
global before
but actually in fact it's the largest
broadband cable provider in europe
which means they supply sort of tv and
internet over the cable
and you may know them from some of their
more familiar brands
um like in the netherlands ziggo
in belgium telenet um in the uk as
virgin media
and by its older trade name upc in other
countries
so what i want to talk about today is
the uh the
the new digital tv platform uh that
liberty global has built so it's serving
4k digital content
to over a million customers and they do
this
by using what's called a set-top box
mainly so you may know these sort of
digital tv boxes that you get when you
get your subscription
and also supplementary an app
so what's the kind of functionality that
we expect
right so a lot of these things you'll
probably recognize for example you can
search
for specific content um you can use a
program
electronic program guide to look up
stuff that's uh you know
uh going on right now and uh
more recently you can also use this to
sort of go back and look to
look at stuff in the past and content
that's been recorded for you
of course there's also going to be all
sorts of ai used to make
tailored recommendations and suggestions
um
and finally a lot of these services also
offer on-demand video choice
and tv series much like you would use in
for example a netflix app so this is the
happy flow
but what if something goes wrong and
where could it go wrong
so in order to explain how that could
happen
let me take you through how content
actually goes from one location
where it's stored into your device or
into your
set-top box so it starts in the home
where
you have all these uh devices and what
you do when you turn on your tv is you
send a request
to a back end to get
all the sort of information that's
displayed on the screen so first it goes
to the hybrid fiber coax network that's
all the cables in the ground that from a
very complex network
all the way back to uh the cable
provider
it goes through a backbone and then into
through a load balance balancer
into um what we call the back end
this back end is actually in fact a very
complex
interconnected system of micro services
that each perform a specific task like
search
recommendation or checking if you've
made the right purchases for specific
content
and this is actually these are all
running in pods
and these pods are running on top of vms
and then these vms are
running on top of a bare metal in a
network of
machines that this uh that this company
has right so there's a lot of complexity
there so what happens if for example one
of these services
uh fails um this could happen if uh for
example during formula one
on a sunday afternoon as you may know
the netherlands has become certainly
very popular because we have this uh
we have max verstappen who's a very good
race car driver
so maybe too many people are trying to
log in at the same time and one of these
services fails
so suppose that it actually doesn't fail
and it it works
then there's still um the matter of
getting the content actually to your
device
so the next step is to send you some
metadata some information on where you
can actually stream the content from
and then you can connect directly to
what's called a content delivery
network all the big companies use this
when they stream content youtube does it
netflix does it a cdn is basically
a distributed network of
servers that store your digital content
but they store it geographically close
to you so that it can get to you very
quickly
right so this is a very old technique
but it's actually very effective
to make sure that you get your uh what
you want to see very quickly
also there something might go wrong you
might uh
it might be the case that you don't have
certain content available maybe it
hasn't been
ingested or prepared properly for you
so that's just a sort of a taste of what
uh could go wrong as you can understand
the digital tv
system it's very complex interconnected
um
and crucially if something goes wrong a
lot of things can go wrong
at the same time right so you won't know
immediately
what's the real cause because everything
is sort of connected to each other
so um we're going to solve this of
course this problem with data
and we have lots of data sources around
this whole ecosystem we have data coming
in
from the set boxes we have detailed
information about the
requests that are going between all
these different microservices
but we also know something about the
performance
uh of the underlying um of the
underlying
infrastructure and finally
the content delivery system of course
also tracks a lot of stuff for us
so what we do is we bring this all
together
in a high performance telemetry
streaming
platform and there we have sort of uh
log document storage easy access with
querying a time series databases
dashboarding and that's what we're going
to use to do the troubleshooting
so how does that go we have
a group of around 250 expert tv
engineers that are usually
you know available in some way or
another to do troubleshooting
they have these very advanced dashboards
at their disposal look at complicated
graphs and and and alerts that they can
uh
that they need to investigate and they
of course can go into the log level data
to uh to find uh more information
but as you can imagine the number of
these dashboards is going to grow
exponentially
and of course as you add more data
sources as the platform grows also in
terms of users
the amount of logs to check can also
grow
so can we reduce the time that's spent
on troubleshooting during an incident by
using ai for iet operations monitoring
or ai ops for short
the main use cases we're looking at
there is to reduce
sort of false positives that come from
using fixed
thresholds for alerts and we can do that
by uh
using anomaly detection so that's
something that we've
extensively worked on we've there's a
lot of interesting stuff
say things to say about it we're using
spark basically to scale out
the facebook profit library to
parallelize sort of anomaly detection on
a lot of time series
uh very interesting topic but out of
scope for this for this talk
um once you know what kind of anomalies
are happening at the same time maybe you
can
identify which one of them which ones
are most correlated and you are probably
part of the same incident
and finally can we actually um find out
what the root cause is
so that's what i want to focus on today
so in order to use troubleshooting to
use ai for this troubleshooting we need
to formulate it as a graph problem
so i'm showing a graph here showing
these components that
that you've been introduced to and we
have this concept of a node
and between nodes they're connected with
edges
and if in this case we have a directed
edge because there's an error on it
right so the direction of the hp request
now you may have heard of adjacency
matrices and on the right here we see
how on the sort of vertical axis what
the origin
of the request is on the horizontal x is
what the destination is
right so a one means it's connected
what if we make it a little bit uh more
interesting we can add
weights to these edges maybe we're uh
interested in the amount of failed
requests between services
we can also see how the adjacency matrix
updates in that case
but as you can imagine this might not
say a lot
that suggests that this number 123 is
the highest
but we don't know if that's actually
normal behavior maybe
that's actually always around this
number so maybe we can do some sort of
normalization of this so for this we've
used
a sort of profit to normalize these time
series to anomaly score
so that at any given time we know how
anomalous
uh the requests from one service to the
next are
so now you can already get a feeling of
which
which services the culprit right it's
it's looking to be the
on-demand services most red arrows big
red arrows pointing towards it
um but maybe we can calculate that
algorithmically
so google larry page and
sergey brin they originally designed the
original pagerank algorithm
for ranking websites when you do a
search
and what they've done is they've
basically
looked at the quality and quantity of
uh links from one website to the next to
determine these edge weights
and then they simulate the behavior of
an individual that's surfing the
internet um
to determine uh which websites they're
most likely to end up in
in the end based on how many links
between the websites there are
so it's kind of a random walk so what
does it look like very simply we start
maybe at the
stb and we follow the edges proportional
to the
edge weights so we with the probability
of taking each step proportional to the
edge weights
so how do we calculate this numerically
so as you see on the right i've
normalized this adjacency matrix and
i've done that by
out degree so out degree is the sum of
outgoing
edge weights or if you have an
unweighted graph it's just the sum of
outgoing at
the number of outgoing edges so you can
see that the horizontal
uh the rows basically add up to one
so it's effectively acting as a
transition probability so how likely am
i to go from the std
to the next given surface
we then randomly initialize some node
probability vector
and for some number of iterations we
just update the
uh the probability vector by multiplying
it
by doing a dot product with the
adjacency
matrix right and you can see that if the
sort of the edge uh the edge weight is
very high then that probability
the incoming edge weights are very high
then the probability vector will
after all these iterations uh probably
be also be the largest
now the simulation uh the the
the pure simulation variation of this
also has some probability of restart
right so uh the surfer doesn't always
keep going at some point he stops and he
restarts
and this is something that we
approximate with some damping factor
by the way this this use of iterations
is
it's called a form of a power iteration
solution to this problem
good practice here is also to use self
loops so have some
uh some number on the diagonal as well
because otherwise the algorithm is
always going to
have to move to the next node even if
it's not a very
uh a very relevant outgoing connection
there
[Music]
all right so what does this look like in
code i have my jccc matrix here
[Music]
in the preprocessing i added this this
diagonal
this i matrix and i normalized by the
horizontal axis this is the result
and then very simple implementation of
the pagerank algorithm
as i said initialize the the probability
vector
and multiply it by this uh this
adjacency matrix a number of times
and as you see here in the results
indeed
the on-demand surface is the one that
has the highest probability score after
these iterations
of course there are some limitations
google is no longer using this algorithm
as the only
way to rank websites it's one of the
ways that they do it or
a hybrid way to do it and that's because
it has a
limitation so first of all there's still
a chance of
getting stuck in the deep end of the
graph
so for that it's also possible that
besides the diagonal
to use backward loops so maybe make it
some some part of the matrix
make it symmetrical
another one is the fact that um
the uh the patriarch algorithm has the
ability to use personalization so after
a restart you could use
uh you could assign a higher probability
of restarting at a specific node
using a personalization vector
and but even even giving these two
things so even giving that we
could use maybe some node features it's
essentially still going to be
univariate so it's just one uh
one sort of feature that you can use
either for the nodes or for the edges
and that's essentially the problem when
we run into heterogeneity
and heterogeneity is actually when you
look at graph problems in real life um
that's actually the most common
situation but when you look at them in
theory
it's the least dealt with so in our case
we have these two types of nodes with
the setup box which generates
completely different data than all these
microservices
and this is something that the pagerank
algorithm is not meant to handle
and one last point is it's essentially a
ranking algorithm so it will just
tell you it will give give you a
proportion
of how important all the nodes are but
it won't tell you anything about if
there is an issue going on
in general in our use case we have
um we have some incident but sometimes
actually most of the times there's not
an incident right so we're not
interested
in finding the most important uh or the
most
failing surface we're interested in
knowing if
service is failing
um so uh what you can do sort of to try
and extend this this page rank
uh thinking maybe we can use some deep
learning approaches
and a very interesting one that's very
recent is
inspired by image convolutions so if you
would
visualize a visualize an image
as basically all the pixels to be
organized on a grid
and connected to their closest neighbors
an image convolution is of course where
you use some sort of kernel
to move over these over the graph or
move over the pixels
and aggregate information pull
information
from the pixel features so can we extend
this analogy to graphs
well we can so it's essentially the same
only it's much more much less densely
connected
so here as well we can use a kernel but
in this case
the kernel we're going to use is the
adjacency matrix because it tells us
which nodes are neighboring each other
and using the jcc matrix that's how we
can pull
the node feature information from one
feature to
the next in the local neighborhoods
so you can think of it as uh going
through the graph and looking at the
neighborhood for each
node and in the problem that we've been
discussing
this would be for example the
neighborhood around the search service
and this would be the neighborhood
around the
purchase service
so how does it look like if we want to
build the actual
keras layer for example so we have our
our graph on the left side again whereas
just for simplicity for now
uh i've just assumed that all the node
types are the same so we have two
node features it can be any arbitrary
number but at least they all have
the same amount of features we take our
jsc matrix
we multiply it by the node features
matrix
and we multiply that by some dense
kernel
and you can see already essentially what
you're doing is you're
using the jccc matrix to propagate
node feature information through the
graph and
of course you're going to have some ways
to learn which information is more
crucial to pass on
as compared to other information and
this is why it's called a form of
message passing
and so you can make this layer yourself
in keras it's
very easy the only thing you need to
remember is to
pass both the adjacency matrix and the
the the note feature matrix as uh
densors at the same time as you're
creating the uh the layers um and after
that it's
uh just two dot product products that
you have to
calculate
but if you remember as i said we
actually don't
often have that case where all the node
features
are exactly the same very often we have
data from different sources
so we have this heterogeneity so what
can we do about that so one
very simple approach uh that
that i found was successful is to just
create first an embedding layer
after both sets of uh node features
and just adding the result right so or
you can do some multiplication or maybe
if you're really uh if you're really um
feeling lucky you could use maybe some
sort of retention mechanism
but essentially uh in some basic
examples
this turned out to be quite effective
and then you actually go back to your
previous situation right you just have
two features
which we can then pull through a graph
convolution
and this is how that looks so we have
this embeddings on the first layer
features
and then we can use the regular graph
convolution
so this is where graph deep learning
usually ends up
and then the remark is always okay now
you can use it for downstream
prediction tasks like node
classification
link prediction forecasting anything
that you want to use structural
information for
uh in our case we're interested in this
root cause so for every
um for every node we have this soft max
output so all the probabilities sum to
one um
to identify whether each node in the
graph is having an issue
or not
and this is information of course that
we would like to
be supplied by by end users so what are
some learnings
uh normalizing this adjacency matrix is
super important
probably the first few times it doesn't
learn anything it's because of that
and the in our case these labels for
root causes were very sparse
so some services barely have any
incidents
so we've had some success using uh
sample weights for that
uh but of course you know there are
probably
many more interesting approaches you can
take there
so what does it look like in code um
[Music]
this is the case for when we use the the
two feature sets
embedding so we basically just
concatenate
the inputs by using these two uh
embedding layers uh and after that we
can
basically use any number of graph
convolutions depending on how
far you want information to be passed
and it's good practice to use a dropout
in between
so how do we how could one
implement some practice
[Music]
so maybe we start out with this google
pagerank algorithm to already have
some unsupervised approach to at least
start generating some labels
and then these labels can be validated
by expert engineers
either reject or accept them which of
course then
uh becomes a sort of feedback loop where
then we can
take more leverage take more advantage
of uh
of diverse feature sets uh maybe even
time involving information over time
initial results show us that around
from hand labeling around uh 100 to 200
quality labels could
help to jump start this this system
and the main challenge we're facing
right now is to actually start
collecting these labels on a structural
basis because the engineers are of
course very busy people
one of the things that i was very
interested in a recent project
that might be interesting for this is to
use sort of rule-based label generation
and the snorkel project has some really
interesting
magic going on on how to actually
generate better labels uh from uh from a
collection of uh
labeling rules so i really uh yeah i
urge you to have a
look at that as well
so what are some extensions um
remember the pagerank algorithm actually
you can use it as a
as an output layer in your neural
network as well it's a very
uh uh as you remember these uh these uh
power iterations you can actually have
that also in a
keras layer and effectively in many
cases you don't even need all these
graph convolutions anymore
you can just have very simple dense
layers in between
and then at the end you can use the
you can use the pagerank algorithm to
just uh propagate
uh the softmax output that you've gotten
like you would originally do with
with pagerank so basically you're using
no network to learn
the uh some information from the nodes
and then just use pagerank to uh to
finish the finish the task basically
uh one thing to note of course that as i
said before this only works for
for ranking problems
and this is how this looks i also have
shared
uh in the discord github page with
what some of these examples worked out
so you can look into them if you
if you want to later
so another one that's very interesting
is that uh
you may have a question or you may be
asking already yourself but hey wait
you're really looking at this sort of
snapshot in time
failed requests over what period of time
usually we look at
five minutes but actually this is the
graph is dynamic right it's constantly
changing
there's temporal information in the
features and in the edges
so so far we've solved this problem by
normalizing this time series using
the facebook profit library so we
haven't
needed this solution very often yet but
many real world problems will have this
problem
of time evolving
features so what's one interesting
approach
that you can take there is if you have
a sequence of time steps every the node
features at every time step
you can pull those through a graph
convolution
and then pass the output to a set of
gru's
which can then in turn be used for a
downstream prediction task
in our case it would be this root cause
classification
so i also highly recommend looking at
this uh
this this paper these kinds of
approaches
all right so uh working towards a
wrap-up
so for us it was also very much a sort
of an
adventure or or a sort of um
taking a deep dive into this area of
graph deep learning
and i feel that
it's in many ways really still in its
infancy
um there's little to no standardization
in
uh the common uh deep learning
frameworks that we know like pytorch or
tensorflow
so you'll find yourself really sort of
looking at all these papers from all
over the place and many of them
have only been published last year uh
this graph conclusion has only been
invented spatial graph conclusions are
only invented like
three years ago so um
[Music]
and and and even then if you
uh try to apply these algorithms in the
real world your graph problems actually
can be slightly different
or more complicated than the one in the
paper
and this especially goes for this
heterogeneous problems and temporal
problems
so there's no one-size-fits-all solution
and that's a crucial thing right so so
it's very hard at this point to have a
library that has just an api that
sees what your graph problem is and then
arranges everything under the hood you
really have to think about that yourself
so there are some interesting projects
on this a stellar graph there's also a
company behind it
and they've taken the approach to
to implement lots of algorithms for lots
of papers
and their backends are sort of inspired
by this network x
graph analytics library and lastly
google deepmind is working in a project
called graph nets but it's much more low
level
and really also aimed at solving core
ai questions
so just to give you an idea of
how that uh how that mismatch between
sort of theory and reality goes
uh so these are all the algorithms that
are implemented by
stellar graph they're all from a
different paper
and these are how they map to specific
attributes of your graph problem so is
it heterogeneous
is it directed are there edge weights is
it temporal
are there no features as you can see not
one of them actually tackles all of them
um and probably if you dive into it
there's probably going to be some
specific that doesn't map to your
problem either
so now the question is is such an
approach going to work in the end right
that we have a million solutions
where you have to find the right one
all right to conclude so i hope we
convince you today that with ai ops we
can help reduce the time spent
troubleshooting
using stuff like normal detection
correlation and automated root cause
detection
with graph deep learning if we set it up
in the proper way we can jump start
learning system as we collect labels
and yeah some notes on this field in
general i think
it's reaching it's a very exciting field
with many applications
um there's a lot more standardization
going to be needed uh
yeah before you can uh really solve
problems out of the box
so let's make sure we give a distance
for the last part of the conference
right dennis yes
yeah thank you very much for your talk
um yeah so a few questions
so you explain it's a really new and
exciting field
so but what do you see in terms of
applications what can you foresee in the
future what possible applications could
be
um as a very good question so
uh in in in this field of opera i.t
operations monitoring the application is
very obvious
because it very quickly becomes about
this topology of interconnected parts
um but actually there are many people
argue that
uh you can formulate any almost any
machine learning problem
as a graph problem right there's always
going to be uh
uh links between different data sets
different components
uh uh that you know describe some sort
of causality that's why of course
many people work with uh with bayesian
networks
so there's lots of stuff in the fields
of
you know logistics uh we recently talked
to a company that's working with
shipping technology
but of course traffic prediction that's
a very classic one uh
the graphnet's uh google deepmind came
out with an interesting
uh work on that recently so yeah i would
say
lots of opportunities okay cool and
would you say that like the
traffic uh uh examples that one
part that makes the problems interesting
is because you actually have very big
graphs right just like any possible
route that you can take across the world
yeah so do you think this really helps
like having your deep blurring algorithm
break down on specific parts of the
graph
um so you mean that it could that it
could break because
the graphs are very complicated or well
makes learning more efficient because
you can like localize the learning
around specific parts of your graph
especially when the graph is really big
yeah yeah that's a that's an interesting
point also about that there's some
that's sort of the difference in uh
graphic learning between inductive
and and uh and transductive uh learning
i think
that's where you have the sort of
inductive learning then uh you actually
sort of learn local representations of
your network so if there's new data
coming in or new
connections being made um then you don't
need to update the whole graph or the
whole network
so that's that's a very interesting
point and and that's probably why they
had
this success at uh deepmind yeah
okay cool interesting and uh one other
question is uh you
uh nicely illustrated your feedback loop
for the people labeling the data yeah so
if you explore
any ways of doing some active learning
to label
specific things that's a very good
question and actually
uh that's
i had i have some papers that i wanted
to look at on that and that's really
going to be
the next step i think because that's
going to make this this process a lot
more efficient right because then we
really focus on the important things
rather than just
having them label anything so that's a
very good suggestion yeah
okay perfect thank you very much